el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ha
comentado por primera vez en público y
en detalle la situación después de los
ataques desde Ucrania a la región rusa
de vélgorda reconocido que Rusia tiene
un problema con esas incursiones Pero ha
avanzado que está en vías de ponerle
solución ha mencionado incluso la
posibilidad de crear una zona sanitaria
no sabemos exactamente a qué se refiere
en Ucrania para evitar ataques como es
en ese caso se incluiría la región
ucraniana de hardcos que los rusos
intentaron tomar sin éxito al principio
de la invasión también ha firmado Putin
una importante enmienda a una ley que
permitirá a partir de ahora retirar los
pasaportes a los jóvenes reclutados para
el ejército esto en la práctica hará que
sea mucho más difícil todavía más huir
de una posible segunda movilización para
ir a luchar al frente ucra